I feel like
I feel like Marvel catfished me
and I don't like it what is going on
guys welcome back to the channel I'm
your host Warren Thompson and we just
got the finale for Marvel studios's
secret Invasion and I've seen
what you have all said about it I've
asked you on Twitter I've seen it in the
comments go ahead and still just let me
know now that you've had time to process
it a little bit what you thought about
the series as a whole in the series
finale let me know in the comments but
I've seen a lot of your replies already
and oh my gosh it's got a a 13 percent
on Rotten Tomatoes 13 Rotten Tomato
score right now so I've heard what
everybody has said I've I've heard the
complaints and I have some of my own
and I'm kind of disappointed because I
feel like the first few episodes were so
good
and then they completely shifted kind of
from the focus now there are a few key
scenes that I want to talk about
and I there are a lot of parts of the
finale that I do enjoy I do think the
fight was cool the CGI was little in
some parts but I think Marvel kind of
slapped Us in the face with this finale
because they actually went against some
of their own principles and some things
that they said about the series which is
odd but let's go ahead and dive into it
first things first
I know everyone's asking the big
question
Roadie how long has he been a scroll for
was it right after Civil War
was he a scroll in Infinity war was he a
scroll in Avengers end game I think that
this would be the
biggest slap in the face that you could
give us
is if Roadie truly did if the scroll
really did swap places with Roadie right
when he got hurt in Civil War I don't
think that's the case but that might be
wishful thinking on my part me not
wanting that to be the case because if
you think about
the final scene for Tony Stark not the
hologram scene when he's alive
Rhody comes down
puts his hand on his face and gives him
that little smirk that little smile
that's like you did it but you're about
to die
that best friend like I'm proud of you
but I'm sad you're about to go it's it's
really emotional I get emotional
thinking about it you're just gonna
negate that
if you say that
Brody's been a scroll since Civil War
that scene gone
right gone it doesn't mean anything it
wasn't Roadie that's why I think they're
going to keep that but if they don't
it's gonna be huge slap in the face an
extremely big
slap in the face now I want to go into
the scene with Fury and graphic which
like isn't Fury and graphic it's Gaia
and gravic and that's the big slap in
the face because in this scene
so much is getting resolved
like the feelings are finally coming out
and I'm I was very impressed with
Kingsley benedir's acting in this
because I truly felt
Graphics frustration his hopelessness
his desire for Revenge
because as as Fury we're going to say
fury because gravic thinks it's Fury we
know it's Gaia but we're gonna say Fury
as Fury is finally admitting yes it's my
fault yes I screwed up you know what I
found out like right away
this you know plan isn't gonna work
because there's no other planet out
there
for you guys to call a home
so it should be
like the resolve but like there is no
resolve between graphic and fury that's
my issue there is none because Fury
never addresses graphic it's Gaia and I
know that she has his memories and
everything like that and can kind of
relay emotions but it isn't the same
it's not and here's my biggest problem
with this is finally graphic is like
getting answers this was his hero Fury
was his hero and Furious finally saying
I'm sorry I failed you and fury says I
realize the only way to find yellow home
was to make one here on Earth and
there's this awesome moment and you can
see it on his face where graphic is just
like why didn't you do that
then why didn't you do that and you can
just tell that he wants more than
anything for that to be true he wants
more than anything
for Fury to have done that and for the
scroll to have a place on Earth
where they could call home to where he
didn't have to Rebel to all he where he
didn't have to do any of this to where
Fury could have still been his hero you
can tell he wishes that is what happened
and it's this big moment for graphic
right he that's like a vulnerable part
and he's not very vulnerable in this
series and he just looks at him he's
like why didn't you do that and
it's not Fury and I'm just like this is
where I say Marvel kind of contradicted
themselves and the director came out and
said you know the finale very much is
about the resolvement between gravic and
fury but it wasn't at all because it
wasn't Fury technically
Fury and gravic
did not interact in the finale at all
they didn't it was gaian gravic and then
Fury so we're gonna come back to the
fight because I actually did enjoy the
fight but let's go to the scene with
Fury scroll roadie
salzworth fallsworth Sonia fallsworth
whoops and uh the president
uh
this whole scene could have been done in
like a minute
right like I get it you're building up
like the president decided launched the
bombs blah blah blah blah false words of
freaking she's awesome she comes in
cleans up
somehow knows the exact room and closet
that they're gonna take the president to
on a different floor and is there and
then Fury just kind of comes in a little
bit at the end shoots two darts takes
two guys out and then it's like hey that
guy's a scroll and they spin like this
entire time going
I'm not a scroll that's crazy president
shoot him Fury going no Mr President
shoot him he's a scroll just shoot him
why didn't fallsworth just shoot him
obviously it would have revealed that he
was a scroll the entire time bam done
scene's over hey call off the bombs we
don't have much time
for people who say they don't have much
time they really do waste a lot of time
and it's two people who usually just
shoot people
so that was I'm like that's kind of bad
writing I feel like I feel like it's not
in character and like oh the president
has a gun a fury shoots him he's gonna
like no like
look the president's hurt probably not
trained in combat probably not gonna
have a good shot shoot the scroll real
quick grab the gun from the president
Bosworth can do that she's already shown
us her capabilities right it it just
seems like a waste of a scene I would
have rather had Fury interact with
Graphics somehow and don't tell me it's
the radiation because apparently there
have been humans in that place being
exposed to radiation for a pretty long
time and they seem to be fine they might
have another arm grow out of them
eventually but yeah so that was my
that's my Quan with that scene and then
so Fury is really like in this this
series was about Fury
so I feel like that's not a good ending
for Fury and yeah we're going into the
Marvels but like it we shouldn't have to
rely on that so Fury's beginning is with
his wife
and I don't know how many people care
about that
right like I don't care that much I
think it's cool that they showed us that
and I was like oh wow he has a wife oh
wow his wife's a scroll oh wow he knows
that his wife is a scroll but they
introduced her in this episode in this
series
and we've known for you for how long
and I feel like this is a kind of
becoming a classic problem for Marvel
unfortunately
where they don't give these characters
that they introduce enough time to
really develop
for us to really care about him I think
that's a big problem right like I I am
interested in this relationship between
the two of them but in all honesty we
didn't know much about it and even at
some points it looks like Fury might not
even care like of course he cares but
it's like he was gone for such a long
time he kind of just like abandoned his
wife so he doesn't care should we care
right like it's just pretty weak in
terms of
any type of wrap up there really wasn't
and now we just have a lot of questions
and from what I know
Miss Marvel is not going to answer those
questions
so I don't know those are my qualms with
these scenes but I will say I did find
the fight kind of cool the CGI was not
was not that good but it was really cool
I thought it was visually cool to see
all these different characters that they
were turning into mostly their arms
right
I'm really kind of over the whole
let's give a character ultimate power
without having that character really
work for it
that's kind of becoming a thing it's
kind of you know Captain Marvel saying
too it's just like oh all of a sudden
we're just gonna introduce this
character and they are going to be the
strongest character you've ever seen we
are not going to see them struggle much
yes we saw Gaia struggle she lost her
parents we get that but again this was
all done very quickly
you know we have 38 minute episodes and
a really quick finale you know this
would have been really great to see from
Gaia if she could have been built up a
little bit more this should have been
Nine episodes and the episode should
have been all at least 45 minutes then
it would have been like wow that's
really cool guy who worked up to her
revenge and now she's one of the
strongest so that's the funny thing is
she is now the strongest character in
the Galaxy possibly the universe right
she has so many powers like she is
Captain Marvel times 20. I counted 23
different dnas that they showed us at
least there could be more
so
what happens then you know that's
obviously something that's going to be
addressed down the road again that's
something else that did not get wrapped
up that we would like some questions to
you but it is nice to know that Amelia
Clarke's character is going to be
sticking around in the MCU I thought it
would be a waste if they killed her off
and Amelia Clark was just gone because
she's fantastic you know overall the
series I thought was pretty good
I just think it finished really weak it
started off strong like the first few
episodes were great and then it just
didn't I think it has something to do
with time
they didn't give him enough time like
how are these episodes 30 something
minutes long how did it decrease as it
went and it had a 200 million dollar
budget
so I think Marvel Studios is pushing
back from the Disney plus content and
hopefully that means they'll have a
little bit more time and money to put
towards the Disney Plus shows that they
do produce hopefully they can be Nine
episodes because they need to be longer
all these recent ones we've gotten have
seemed really rushed and I think that's
a pretty big problem but overall I still
like the Disney plus content it was fun
to watch and I genuinely enjoyed it
mostly and you know if it finished week
is my only problem it was some it was
some you know cool stuff to watch we saw
some cool things in it that final scene
really was cool but it was so short
that I feel like we didn't get to live
most of it and that was like the only
thing that kind of like
was super exciting the rest of it was
kind of just a little lackluster
unfortunately but again overall I
enjoyed the series I thought it was
great
um but let me know what you all thought
I've seen most of your comments but go
ahead let us know your full analysis in
the comments down below don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items and some DC items as well
you can also follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf
please